εναιεμπλάκικα μετα χρηματο οικονομικά λόγο τι εμπηρίας που από εκτηςσά και ίδρις α μια να
μια ανεπαιρεία διαχείρισης κεφαλέων και τώρα το τελευταίο μας βήμασε αυτή την κατευθύση είναι μια
ένα γκρούπετεριών με διάφορες επενδήσει με διάφορες ταιρίες που ας σχότιντε στων τομέα των επενδήσαπάντα
σουν κόντα στο δημοκρατικό συναγερμό λόγο και του πατέρα το άνστουρανιο ανίδη τισε έκανε να
έρθεις πιον προστά τώρα αυτή την περιώδ ναι όπως το ίπες πνταήμου κοντά στο δημοκρατιος
συναγερμό και το στο τονίσα γιατί πολύ πολεί να μην ξέρουν ναι το μιχάλη ότι
εδώ και χρόνια είναι κοντά στο μοκρατικό συναγερμό γιατί των έμαθαν τώρα από τη ναι
από τη θέση τις άμο όπως το βλέπω οι οικογένεια μου και οι επίδραση που
είχε πάνω μου οικογένεαμου ήταν ακριώς αυτή δηλαδί το μεσημέρι που τρόγαμε μαζί με ο
πατέρα μου μιλούσανα πολιτικά το βράτυ πουκαθόμαστα διαβάζε δεν πολιτικάγραφεί πολιτικά βιβλία πολιτικά περιοτικά θυμούμε
ο πατέρς μου έφενε περιωτικά από το εξωτερικό τότε που δεν είχαμε τόσε να ευκολη
πρόσβαση θυμούμε κάθε βράδυ η ώρα έντε κάθα πηγαίνναμε στο λώρι τις τη λευκωσία στο
περίπθον του λόρι να πιάσουμε ι εφημερίες που είαι ελλάδα που έρχονταν από τηείναι ελλάδα
τι θέλω να πω θέλω από ότι πάντα μασταν ε βλεβλεγμένι μετα πολιτικά με την
έννεια του να βλέπουμε τς ξελίξεις να έχουμε να απόψεις οι εμπλοκιμο στο δημοκραιος γα
μο ήταν πολύ μικρής θέσεις οιμον οργανωτικός της προοπορίας για κάποια χρονιά και μετά ακολουθεή
ταν τηνγκαργέρα μου ότι